porque esa declaración de lópez obrador
está méxico realmente en capacidad de
capturarlos
bueno yo creo que la declaración del
presidente de lópez obrador viene
digamos un poco a reflejar que las
prioridades de ambos países no
necesariamente están yendo hacia el
mismo lugar estas recompensas que
anunció el gobierno de eeuu llegan a tan
solo un día de que entrará en vigor el
entendimiento bicentenario un nuevo
acuerdo bilateral que el para el
presidente lópez obrador significaba
pues prácticamente el fin de la guerra
contra las drogas el fin del
descabezamiento de organizaciones
criminales y lo que sucede es que
gobierno eeuu dice no yo sigo teniendo
como prioridad desarticular a las
organizaciones criminales que trafican
drogas méxico el cártel de sinaloa en
específico sigue siendo mi prioridad y
esto contrasta un poco con la actitud
que el gobierno mexicano ha tenido
frente a esta organización en específico
recordemos que hace un par de años fue
liberado el hijo de joaquín guzmán en un
en un
operativo fallido en el estado de
sinaloa y además que esto sucede también
durante un año 2021 que hubo elecciones
para gobernador en los del pacífico
mexicano y donde hay acusaciones muy
serias de que el cártel de sinaloa apoyo
participó operando a favor de morena que
es el partido del presidente así es que
puede ser esta una nueva fuente de
tensión entre las organizaciones de
seguridad mexicanas y estadounidenses en
carlos sigamos sobre el mismo tema y el
episodio que usted menciona el mismo
lópez obrador fue el que recordó que en
octubre del 2019 el ordenó liberar a
ovidio guzmán después del operativo en
el que lo capturaron en sinaloa pero que
detonó una reacción muy violenta de un
grupo del grupo criminal y que puso en
riesgo a la población eso hace pensar
que el gobierno está lejos de controlar
el narcotráfico
sí y sin duda y es en méxico además
digamos puso en cuestión no sólo la
capacidad sino la voluntad del gobierno
mexicano de golpear al crimen organizado
ha sido muy criticado el gobierno de la
república de méxico porque prácticamente
no ha habido ninguna detención de gran
calado importante en contra de
organizaciones criminales y claramente
lo que estamos viendo es que para eeuu
esto sigue siendo una prioridad esto
generó tensión la liberación de ovidio
guzmán posteriormente cuando el gobierno
eeuu arrestó al ex secretaria la defensa
de mexico eso generó que el gobierno de
mexico quitara las visas a los agentes
de la dea algo que apenas se resolvió
hace apenas un mes entonces estamos en
una coyuntura donde los pareciera que
las prioridades y los objetivos de ambos
países en un problema que es binacional
no están alineadas hacia el mismo
sentido y eso ha generado tensiones
diplomáticas y por supuesto también
desde mi punto de vista descoordinación
para golpear a estas organizaciones que
causan daño en ambos lados de la
frontera